every once in a while truth gets out on
fox news and usually it gets out because
Shepard Smith told the truth less
frequently truth gets out on Fox News
because Chris Wallace told the truth
other times it just slips out of
someone's mouth accidentally and what we
might in some ways even call in a
Freudian way Fox & Friends was anxiously
and excitedly reporting about the
arrival of their hero Donald Trump in
Singapore to make Big Boy negotiations
with Kim jong-un when Fox & Friends
weekend host Abbey Huntsman I guess they
sort of have like their D team on the
weekends I'm not really sure Abbey
Huntsman said that the two dictators
Trump and Kim jong-un would be meeting
the following day the two dictators
would be meeting Trump and Kim jong-un
here's the clip from Fox & Friends
there isn't of the United States Donald
Trump about to walk down those stairs
stepping foot in Singapore as we await
this historic summit with the North
Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon Anthony
talk to us about this moment this is
history we are living regardless of what
happens in that meeting between the two
dictators what we are seeing right now
this is history correction Abby the
dictator and the guy who would like to
be a dictator are going to be meeting
and the apology came later in the day
from Abby Huntsman saying she wants to
point out that earlier as you know on
live TV sometimes you don't always say
things perfectly I called both President
Trump and Kim Jong hoon a dictator I did
not mean to say that my mistake so I
apologize for that
was it a mistake Abby or is this part of
the effort to condition the Fox News
audience to like dictators listen even
if there was collusion it wouldn't be
illegal listen even if Trump was a
dictator that's not necessarily a bad
thing as long as he's a conservative
dictator who we like probably just a
slip-up I'm mostly joking but a very
funny one Trump is not a dictator he
would like to be one he's actually
having a hard time getting people to do
what he wants especially foreign leaders
who were way smarter than he is and I
guess what we can say is in the United
States we still do have the rule of law
at least on
paper and that rule of law has stopped
Trump from doing some of the things he
would no doubt like to do and the path
to dictatorship is actually not so much
set by the guy who wants to be dictator
but it's opened by those who don't stop
the would-be dictator right and what I
mean is it's up to everybody else to
prevent Trump the dictator and to be
clear I'm not literally saying the u.s.
is becoming a dictatorship but it's a
sort of de facto Western democracy
pseudo dictatorship authoritarian
paradise right that's that's really what
it is that Trump would want I don't know
that he literally wants a dictatorship
in this sort of despot type of way maybe
he does but I don't I don't know and I
was thinking it's actually really
working in our favor that Trump doesn't
know how government works because if
Trump knew how government worked he
would be way better at manipulating it
to his advantage and to the obvious
detriment of the American people and I'm
reminded of a bit of Edward R murrow's
writing on this Edward r murrow wrote as
quoted by AM Sperber in Murrow his life
and times quote if they deceived her
confused public is betrayed into
creating or allowing to be created an
America in which it loses faith
democracy will not survive very very
appropriate to Trump and more generally
towards 2018 United States of America
and less away why are we so worried
about Trump speaking to Kim jong-un
anyway right Trump's going to have a
conversation with one of the most
dangerous people on the planet and the
worst possible outcome after all there's
only nuclear war I don't know why
anybody would really be so concerned
about that it's gonna be fine I don't
know why anybody would be skittish about
this meeting we will know about very
very soon send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman